the agenda for this presentation uh
we're gonna there's four major areas uh
or really play three major areas and
think a little bit about the future at
the end but yeah so we're gonna look at
new language features um then we're
gonna look at new runtime features and
we're gonna also look at the deprecation
removals
and a few other changes to kind of know
about
and i said a little bit towards that and
we'll look a little bit at the future
we're actually we'll actually take a
little bit more for a look at java 18
now that it's starting to get somewhat
solidified in what's going to be
delivered
here next march
if you leave this presentation with an
intense desire to know more uh we at the
java
platform group and the developer
advocate team there we have a lot of
great sources for
additional information um first is our
recently launched dev.java where we have
a lot of great tutorials and a lot of
other great content
for learning about java you know
including also like a whole list of like
all the java user groups around the
world so you can find ways to learn to
connect with other developers around the
world uh inside.java if you want to kind
of keep up on what's going on in open
jdk the development what's coming next
and so on this is a really great site to
follow
our youtube channel where we're pretty
out content pretty much weekly and we
also have a podcast uh which is also
pretty great uh nikolai leads nikolai
parlock if he's presented here before
he'll be here to present uh he primarily
runs the inside java newscast we have
another episode coming out here really
soon with that
i do the
weekly sip of java uh every monday so
check that out a minute long video and
then also jose uh he runs the jet cafe
where he goes in depth on some of the
upcoming jeps with java or even some
recently released ones as well so a lot
of great content to kind of keep up on
what's going on in the on in the world
of java and java developments
all right so let's actually properly get
into the presentation now
with some new language features
so the first one i want to cover is text
blocks text blocks were added in java 15
and the jeff for this is 378. if you're
not familiar with the term jeff that
stands for jdk enhancement proposal and
that is just a process for when there's
a somewhat substantial amount of work i
think it's usually
kind of stipulated around two or so
weeks maybe a little bit longer a
developer time um it's put together as a
jdk enhancement proposal and that lays
out like the motivation the goals
and the reasoning behind why a new
feature a new are a change is being made
to the jdk
and these can be great sources of
information
for
uh for what is being added to our for
the new feature being covered
so here
is like the one for
text blocks and like i said it kind of
has a history of of the feature the
motivation behind it and and so on
so like i said for for a lot of these
features i'm you know only generally be
able to give a few minutes for each
given feature but if there's something
more you want to know about it
definitely use that jep number as a
guide and that will send you to one of
these that can give you a lot more
detail information on that new feature
let's see
there we go uh so with that said though
text blocks
uh
if you have spent
literally more than a couple of months
as a java developer
you've run into at some point where
you've needed to work with html json
like in this example
xml or some other kind of formatted
um uh
language within the actual strings of
your code
and
oh yeah yeah thanks thanks so thanks for
that clarification that bell um
yeah but uh
uh where you have to kind of work with
like some sort of formatted language
within like an actual string uh of your
code and we can see here in this very
simple example with this four fields and
no nesting
you know because we're pretty familiar
with this code we can kind of see what's
going on but it's still very difficult
to know exactly what's going on in this
code and there's a lot in here i had to
put in all these new line characters
these tab statements have to escape out
all these double quotes and of course
you know it could be very easy to forget
like a comma if we get any sort of
nesting in here it can be difficult to
get that and of course we're printing
this out it can be really difficult to
always make it clear like how i want it
to be properly formatted
all this to say it's just a lot of work
it's it's very difficult and it's not
clear what exactly is going on here
so
added with java 15 is text blocks where
they're denoted by
triple quotes at the start and at the
end and then within it the needs for
formatting is greatly reduced so now if
i want to have another line well i just
hit the return
you know key and i don't actually have
to do like a new line tab a new line
character
this formatting here the spacing here is
preserved um within the code so if i
printed this out it would print out
exactly how this would kind of look here
uh i don't also have to uh escape out
all the quotes as well because you know
it's to know by triple quotes instead of
a single quotes for a quote-unquote
standard string
um
from here
let's see where was that so um one thing
and it's a pivot longer discussion but
there's like a whole thing about
incidental white space and more or less
it's kind of based upon as you can kind
of see here in the jump really where
this tuple quote and closing tuple code
is kind of located more or less
uh basically
where you want your answer little white
space to be ignored is where you want to
put these total codes like here i i want
all this white space to be ignored if i
maybe wanted this to be formatted a
little bit i could move my triple quotes
a little bit here to the left
um that's more or less kind of how you
want to follow it uh there's there's a
bit more rules around it but like if you
kind of follow this that's it'll get you
the expected printing out
of it
um string formatting works just like it
would with the normal straining i mean
really what these are is within the jvm
internals there's there's no difference
between these strings it's all kind of
handled by the compiler
um
you know there's no there's no
underlying difference so if you want to
still use like the string formatter to
kind of um insert different um
characters or different values into your
strings
this will work exactly like it would
with like again a
a normal
string would
uh also if you maybe have like a really
long single string that you want to have
printed out
uh but it's just too long you don't want
to have to do like the plus scene of
like all the strings as well
if you put a backspace at the very end
of a line
then it you don't want to have any other
whitespace or anything after it but if
you put the backsplit or the backslash
here then it will ignore the character
turn and so then this really long or
this literally long line string here
would be printed out by single line by
the um if you were to do system out
print line here
the next i want to cover is swiss
expression
which was added initially in java 14 and
the jeb for it is 361
and so it's
switch statements so we're all kind of
familiar with like the case and then the
um the colon syntax that's still
entirely valid if you still want to work
with that and of course all of us we
have many existing
case statements as well that um you know
we don't want to necessarily have to
change and update but now case has been
our switch has been extended to also be
able to do expressions and that is
denoted by the error operator and so
with that is is that
when this case evaluates to true
only the code to the right of the arrow
operator is executed so we don't have to
put any sort of break statements which
is often you have been a very
frustrating thing for java developers
where you forgot to put a break
statement and then you get multiple uh
cases being executed when that's not
where you were expecting or wanting and
so you had to go in and fix that bug now
there is no fall through really at all
um so that makes it just much more clear
instead of having to put a bunch of
break statements within it
switch expressions can also return value
from them so
here um we have to
we can have it return in this case a
string and for each case you know like
for the day of the month in this case
i'm kind of going by the u.s where
sunday's the first day of the week
um
it will return that value and then you
can print out the the result
so
uh also you can actually i don't think i
have an example in the in this slide
deck but you can actually even do this
with the old switch or
with um switch statements as well where
if you were to put like colon and then
um use the new reserved word yield
that would actually also allow you to
return value from a switch statement
so you can also do that as well
uh also with that so you can also even
execute a code block so if you just
obviously have some sort of more complex
behavior then that can be really
expressed within a single line you can
actually wrap it within
a code block and that will all be
executed if you're returning a value
back from that switch expression then
you will need to use the yield within
the code block as well to return a value
from it um
our throw and accepts it as well so so
when you're it has to result in either a
value or an exception being thrown um if
you're returning your values from it
so you probably also noticed how all
these or you may have noticed how all
these switch expressions have a default
case so expressions have to be
exhaustive
so for the vast majority of cases for
people can be used in java 17 that means
you're going to have to have a default
case within there
but if you're using something here like
i am with like an enum where again i
list out all the days of the week and
then within my switch expression i put
all the different uh values within that
enum well then that means there it
covers all the possible cases so i don't
need a default case from it then
so
um when
as um
well i'll talk about a little bit later
on but like as job is 18
um it'll probably actually be 19 when
it's going to be probably finalized it's
going to be adding and pattern matching
for search expressions which can tie in
with sealed classes which can allow you
to also have another way of writing out
a switch expression that doesn't have to
cover or doesn't have to include a
default case within it
i actually kind of covered that example
in my most recent sip of java which is
covering a preview feature on search
expressions coming in java 18.
on the subject of pattern matching that
is actually going to be an expanding
story for java coming over the next few
releases and the first instance of that
being actually released as a full um
feature is pattern mansion for instance
of
and that was added in java 16 and again
the jeb for that is 394.
so
again this is something that all java
developers are probably to some extent
familiar with where you have some sort
of
value that you know it's maybe coming in
from some sort of an external source and
you don't
like you can't programmatically have it
defined to whatever expected val or
expected type you have it's you want to
have it to be or it could be multiple
types as well
so then we have to write out this code
where if actually a string is an
instance of string then we go into the
code block and
we assign it to some sort of variable
and then we do our work with it
you know just a lot of typing and
there's always going to be some
opportunities then for introducing some
bugs because maybe you don't assign it
correctly
or something like that
so
now we have the
uh pattern variable i think that's what
it's called um but where you can just
say if actually a string instance of a
string then we have this variable that
will then be set to the value of
whatever this is and then of course it
would be of the type now i'm a string
and where we came within that if block
uh can do whatever our work to it
now this
now i'm a string variable it's what's um
called flow scopes so what that means is
that this now i'm a string is available
wherever the compiler knows that this is
definitely true
so 99 of the time this is really how
we're going to be using it within an if
block and then within the the actual um
block of that if statement
will you know do whatever work we want
to it
uh but once we leave that if block well
then this would give a compiler error
because this is no longer in scope
because the compiler doesn't know if
this is evaluated to true or not within
here because that doesn't necessarily
have to be true for the code to get to
this point
um also with like here an example if i
just did an evaluation
block right here
where again i do the nominal string it
would be
a compiler error again here because once
i leave the evaluation block
the compiler doesn't know if this is
actually been set or not
of course also with like an r statement
so here obviously this would be true and
this would be available but
by
necessity um
the only way this r would be evaluated
if this part was false
meaning that now i'm a string has an x
being set and so then this would give a
compiler error but of course with that
and statements you know this would have
to be true before the compiler attempts
to evaluate this or the jbm attempts to
evaluate this
so then um this would be acceptable
um
of course you can kind of get weird with
how this flow scoping would work um not
that over i could recommend doing any of
this but like if i was just to do a knot
and around this
within that if block here now my string
wouldn't be in scope but it would be in
scope here in the else block
um or alternatively same thing but if i
throw an exception then actually
it would be available outside of the if
block because the only way the code
could get here is if this evaluated to
be false so therefore this would need to
be true and you know it would have been
set
up but really 99 again
are about the other 90 of the time um
when we're kind of working with this is
where we have our value coming in we
have maybe this have some sort of
variable that's scoped to the correct
level of where you're going to be
working with it
and you know you would just assign it to
it within
the um if block to then be able to work
with it later
sealed classes uh this was
added in java 17 and stitch up for it is
409
so sealed classes allow you to define
classes or allows you allows a class to
define what subclasses can extend upon
it so here we have user and user can say
only guest customer and admin can extend
off of me
and then these classes would have to
define
um
whether or not you know things can
extend off of it or rather it's also
limited as well and so how this works so
this is kind of like a diagram and this
is how it would actually look in code is
like i would have my
user class that's sealed and it permits
only admin customer and guest to extend
a product then we have um admin and
these classes admin customer and guests
they have to declare if they're going to
be sealed
final or non-sealed for sealed works
exactly the same way where admin says
okay well only then super admin our
normal admin can extend
off of me
the the guest well nothing can extend
the cost off of guests and for customer
it's non-sealed which makes it just act
like a normal class where anything can
extend off of it if it wanted to
so this kind of allows also a
flexibility to it to where
um
if you maybe have some sort of case like
this where you know there's only going
to be three
major types of different kinds of users
but maybe customer would need to be
pretty flexible because you could have
like a like a a really important type of
custom like big customer medium customer
new customer you know maybe you just
need potentially a lot of different new
types of customers over time
this allows a lot of flexibility where
it's not like tightly bound up on user
how stuff can evolve these subclasses
kind of evolve at their own rate as well
but we've all had that within our code
within our organizations where
there's certain kinds of domain objects
or domain concepts where you may have
like some sort of super concept but then
there's only a certain amount unlimited
different variability under it and it
could be good to then actually define
that within code
and we'll also see a little bit later on
how um
we're only just getting just to the very
start of this
how other language features will
actually build upon this concept as well
to actually work together much more
nicely
in the in future iterations of java
the last feature i want a new language
feature i'm going to talk about
is records and it's last but definitely
not least
these were added in java 10 and their
jeff is 395
but uh
records are probably going to be one of
the most important or one of the most
impactful new features added to java
since lambdas and streams are added all
the way back in java 8. again we're at
the very kind of start of it there's
going to be more
beats just kind of added and built upon
on top of records but already they
provide massive benefits for a lot of
use cases and then also a lot of
underlying key benefits for java itself
so the most obvious benefit or the first
benefit developer is going to know is is
going to be with regards to the
reduction in
boilerplate code
so here we maybe have a simple example
of
uh maybe we just have like some data
that's kind of loosely put in here
uh
oh yeah yeah very nice yeah it's very
nice for simplifying code and yeah we're
seeing a really great example here well
we maybe we have like some sort of data
that's at one point and we're going to
maybe just define some sort of like
temporary object to kind of hold that
data
and do something with it and so in this
case we i'm defining like a person
and you know it's the four fields i'm
defining the constructor
and maybe you know i'm going to have to
do some sort of um comparisons on them
so i had to do the hash code and equals
and all together it quickly becomes just
dozens of lines of code just to define
even the simplest of classes
and you know that's obviously very
distracting that we have this part up
here in our code and then like this
whole dozens of lines and then we
finally get back down to here where
we're actually doing the real work with
this code
and so all the meaning within this code
is lost
but with records
all that can be defined within just a
single line here um
in fact actually this is the record's a
little bit better because i also
actually get accessories which i
identify in this code here but yeah all
that can be defined in this single line
of code of person where i define
my class on my record and then now i
define all the components of it and now
i can work with it here so that's that's
the first and most immediate benefit a
lot of developers will notice of course
there's many more benefits as well
uh so so records like the goal of them
is to be a transparent modeling of data
as data and so kind of within that to
kind of um fulfill that goal there are
certain constraints that are being put
on records so for one the super class of
a record is always going to be record
and so subsequently they can't be
extended they can't be abstract and as a
result they're implicitly final you
can't
have another record extend off another
record because then you can't just know
from the definition of a record all the
fields that can contain and then there's
also issues with like the transit of
like
between fields between
subclasses of like how those fields will
be handled so
records are final they can't be extended
it can't be abstract they are replicitly
final
also all the fields within a record are
final
but it's only solidly immutable so if
you have a field that's in me that's
mutable itself like a good example would
be lists um
then there's not any sort of enforcement
that that list is going to be immutable
so if you have a record that has an
arraylist as a field you can add or
remove items from that arraylist
like you could of course but of course
you couldn't have assigned a different
arraylist after initially setting that
record so that's just something to keep
in mind that they're only shallowly
immutable
um if you want to make sure that they're
actually fully immutable make sure that
you're also using immutable types for
the field the underlying fields or
otherwise have some sort of checking to
make sure that their fields aren't being
changed
you can't declare instance fields so i
can't go into
a record so like here
i have my record um i can't go in and
define
like a um another field within record uh
or within the person record within here
uh all the fields within the record are
defined as the components for it um
within the definition of the record so
again that that's a way it can be a
transparent modeling of data as data
um
you can also override the default
implementation of methods which i kind
of just briefly so there or add your own
definitions and i supply add a couple
more bullet points to this but also
serialization
if you've dealt
that deeply with serialization in java
um it's a very much of a mess it's
something i've only really become
particularly familiar with since my time
of joining oracle earlier this year
uh but there's a lot of issues where um
both as a developer where you can kind
of like mess things up or uh potentially
expose yourself to a lot of security
risks and then of course also from this
perspective of
the open jdk as well where there's just
a lot of work a lot of security
vulnerabilities that are exposed because
of the way civilization works
with records though because there are
transparent modeling data as data um the
serialization for records is a lot more
simple that it all kind of goes through
the public apis of a record
um are uses only like a default setting
for how serialization works which makes
it much simpler and much more
protected against many security
vulnerabilities so like that's another
underlying benefit of records as well
that's probably also going to have many
benefits later on as we probably rework
serialization in the future but
nothing specific around that but you
know it's something that has been a
long-term goal within open jdk
uh but as mentioned you can also
override the default implementations for
many methods so let's say if you don't
like the default implementation of
tostring well then you can just create
your own um two-string method
you know does whatever you want you need
it to do
uh of course you can also i mean at the
end of the day these are still classes
so you can just also define your own
method as well if i wanted a two json
method here to print out json
i can easily accomplish that as well
so let's move now into some of the new
runtime features and improvements
uh
so class data sharing is something
that's really underutilized in the java
community that actually have a lot of
benefits particularly in the world of
microservices or particularly functions
or anything kind of like that where
you could have relatively small
applications that maybe need to start
pretty quickly
yes records can implement interfaces uh
and actually i don't have an example of
that but that could be a really good way
of
records working with sealed classes
because of course records you know they
they have to all extend our their super
class is always going to be record and
they can't be abstract and all that as i
mentioned but if you want to kind of
work with records within the context of
sealed classes one really good way of
doing that is with
creating a sealed
interfaces and then having records
implement those interfaces as well so
yes records can implement interfaces
uh great question um
so
back to where it was so class data
sharing is something that's really
underutilized in the java community and
part of that is um
a lot of the new features were added
since java 8 with much of the java
community still
on java 8 so having not really gotten
great chances to use that
and then also it's been a little bit
historically difficult to use so even on
java 11 using apps cds or fcds hasn't
been that great but there's been a lot
of updates to it
to where in particular java 13 we've
created what's called dynamic cds and
pretty much what it allows you to do is
create a
shared data archive by just simply
adding archive classes to exit you run
your class you start it up and you stop
it and it'll create the jvm will create
a dynamic archive
um that you can then read from on the
next startup
what does this all mean so pretty much
whenever you start up a new java
application of course that starts a new
jvm and there's going to be a bunch of
loading of classes that's going to
happen every time and that's going to
happen the same for every time you start
up that application
so obviously there's with there's an
opportunity for an optimization there
and so what cds
does class data sharing or in this case
also app cds
application data steering which allows
you to actually do that for your actual
applications that you're writing
is you allow it the jvm to create a
shared archive that pre-processes all
this class loading into some more
readable format that can then load a lot
quicker also what's beneficial from it
is this
archive can get memory mapped so if you
have many of these same uh if you have
many um java processors running on the
same host they can all use the same
memory location from it which can then
save memory that's only if you're having
them run on the same host so like
um and host i mean like even like a if
you have two docker containers running
on the same um system that would be two
different hosts but if you're having
multiple
um
java applications all kind of running
within the same compute instance or the
same you know app computer
uh they can you can see some memory
savings
from it uh one other thing is is how
this works is uh
really for many of the applications you
write like let's say you're you're
an organization where you're like you're
a spring boot shop or you're using
quarkx or microprofile or whatever
you're using like 90 of all the classes
you're going to be loading are going to
be coming from underlying framework
libraries so really you could probably
just create one um
dynamic archive that can be shared
across kind of like whatever
um shared tech stack that you're using
and not necessarily having to create
like a dynamic archive for each time
for each different application or every
time you release a new version from it
because really probably a lot of that
underlying class structure is not going
to change too much so it's a little bit
easier to maintain these
uh in that way but definitely something
you should definitely check out
um
i forgot to put some like stats in here
but when i was running like a somewhat
simple spring boot application like
spring boot
team has like the pet clinic app they're
like a proof of concept app
um and i think by default it was taking
my my ab system a
2019 macbook pro
about nine seconds to start up by just
with the default and that was with java
16 and then with using app cds it took
it down to about six seconds your
monoliths will vary particularly if
you're during startup you're like trying
to connect out to a database you know
that connection or some other service
it's probably going to really take a lot
longer than any sort of the actual
startup process for the jvm
but there is some sort of real benefits
to using app cds both for
startup memory and then of course and
also cpu usage
gdc um is a new garbage collector it's
kind of like a it's a fundamental
redesign
of garbage collection and just coming
from it also from different
goal priorities uh z doesn't stand for
anything it's just they just decided to
choose z for it
uh
which up for this is 371. uh it's
currently a single generation i think
it's going to eventually be a
multi-generation garbage collector which
will make it much more like the g1
garbage collector which is the current
default garbage collector in the jvm are
like the parallel or i think serial
garbage is also a multi-generational
garbage collector
but
one of the major goals of this of the
zgtg collector is to have extremely low
latency and then also to be extremely
scalable
i think right now like a g1 garbage
collector it particularly
prefers throughput which can be really
great for running like a major batch
process or something like that but for
the web processes is that many
developers software developers kind of
work with it'll be actually much better
to have extremely low latency so that
way
um all your users connecting to your
application get a response back very
fast even if maybe the amount of actual
work being accomplished overall is
slightly lower
so
that was a goal in mind with z2c
and then also again being able to
take on
really huge heaps of memory as well
multi-terabyte in size but even
um but if you want to check out zdc um
let's say it's a full production ready
garbage collector as a jdk 15. um you
can
set the jvm argument to use gtc you know
set whatever your heap size is
and then you may we'll also want to turn
on um
gc or garbage collecting uh debug
logging just to see how that kind of
behaves within your application or
compared to like maybe
the
g1 which you're currently using whatever
garbage collector are currently using at
your organization
all right this is probably the runtime
feature most software developer is going
to be most excited about helpful and all
pointer exceptions just because
every java developer kind of like i was
you know talking about earlier with like
text blocks having the frustration of
working with markup language within your
code
every java developer has had some point
you know ran into some extremely
frustrating mpe where you just get back
you know a null value occurred on some
line of code and you just can't
necessarily know which value was null
because it could be
one two three or well two three four
five more different options on that line
so then that leads you having to go back
and put in some sort of debug statement
to figure what's going out before you
can actually fix the bug
extremely frustrating
uh so back in job 14 we added helpful or
i should say bill soft actually they're
the ones because they had that in their
jvm um they contributed this code to
open jdk to where instead of before we
would just say oh np
a null pointer happened on line seven
now it would actually say what variable
actually was null and then what
what actual method um encountered the
null error making it much more easy and
simple to resolve these issues when they
come up
uh
now a our um
amd
arm architecture 64 support uh it's
supported across all the major operating
systems uh mac os being the last one the
jdk 17. so if you're one of the lucky
java developers to have one of the
really cool nice new m1 macbooks or
maybe the m1 max
macbooks uh you'll notice a pretty
significant improvement probably when
running on jdk 17 and then of course
windows um
got supported back in 16 linux was the
first with jdk9 but actually there's
even been a few other steps that further
supported um are provided better support
for
arms architecture 64 support as well so
there's a there's been ongoing work to
continue to improve
it as well
uh i keep forgetting i need to run this
test again for java 17. but just there's
one thing is also is you do get like
with every new version of java that
comes out there's always new
improvements being put into the jvm
that just improves import performance
you know across memory across
startup
um and runtime
and here uh again using that spring boot
pipe clinic app
just as example but the literal exact
same binary when running it on java 8
you know it would take
about nine or eight and a half seconds
to start up and like just real mock
whatever low test i put together like it
took 137 seconds complete you know it
i'm not like a performance expert so i'm
not going to sit here and say this is
like the best kind of load test ever to
compare them but just using like the
same
hardware in the same binary um you know
it took about six and a half seconds to
start up using uh just java 16
and then it's um
this low test i put together it ran it
in 130 seconds
uh but like you know other examples is
um
recently um one of our uh
uh jvm people klaus uh forgetting his
last name but like he
for java 17 did some work that improved
string that format that i think provided
it with like a
3x or 12x improvement on its um
throughput performance so you know there
can those those little things that can
kind of add up um to connect all
together kind of make your performance
much better and you just get this purely
from upgrading your jvm it's like i said
this is the exact same binary i didn't
have to recompile it in java 17
uh or in this case java 16 to get these
improvements it just you just get that
from just running on a new jvm which is
really cool
uh next i want to talk about uh
deprecations uh removals and other
changes to know about
for deprecations the security manager
has been deprecated for removal with uh
java 17.
you know generally
yeah okay thanks yeah there's a 3x
improvement thank you uh abel for
pointing that out can it quite remember
if it was 3x or something else um
but yeah so security manager uh
to uh is being duplicated removal and
the big thing with this is that
fundamentally it just it was pretty hard
to use for the security manager pretty
much it was um defining at different
levels like what
like what classes and what packages can
it do what certain behaviors
um and fundamentally it's just easier to
manage this stuff at the operating
system level than it is at the
programming or at the java level so the
security manager is being removed but
that does not by any means means java is
becoming less secure
the other is the applet api
applets you know um all the browsers i
think are just allowing the use of
applet anymore because of their
fundamental security issues which is
also kind of the primary use case for
the security manager as well um they are
being marked for removal which adk 17.
they were
deprecated all the way back in jdk 9 but
now they're marked for removal with jdk
17.
um things that actually have
outright been removed from open jdk is
the nas horn javascript engine um that
was removed in jda 15. nash horn still
exists it's still
within the openjdk
like project it's just not shipped with
open jdk anymore so if you still need to
use nasthorn it's actually still out
there
um under
let me see open jdk
yeah so
it's still available um it's not
obviously being actively developed with
the last commit being july 1st but it's
still available out there and still
being worked on so if you still need
that for some reason um you know
it's still um you can still use it
also the cms the clear mark sweep guards
collector that was superseded by the g1
garbage collector which was made the
default garbage collector back in jdk 9.
so
if for some reason your organization
has been relying upon the cms garbage
collector you should be able to make an
easy and seamless translation to the g1
garbage collector that will actually
probably improve your performance as
well
uh the other major change to know about
is the it's the continuing road towards
strongly encapsulating jdk internals
that started with jdk 9 with the
implementation of the java module system
with that initial implementation
um the
jvm argument illegal access permit was
set as a default parameter that allowed
easy reflective access into
um
into certain jdk internal classes our
internal packages
modules sorry
um but now with jdk 16 um the illegal
access permit was no longer a default
parameter um in the jvm and now with jdk
17
this is this has become a no op jvm
argument so
now if you do need legal access or
certain things remain like the sun misc
unsafe um
all these apis here still remain
available without having to do anything
but if there is some other jdk internal
that some library or just the code you
wrote yourself actually needs um
reflective x is accessed into you can
still do ads opens um at the command
line or doing ads opens to a jar
manifest to get that reflective access
into it but it's just there's no longer
a single jvm or you can
put in there that this gives you full um
uh reflective access to all the jdk
internals like you could illegal access
permits
eventually this will be removed so
instead of just being like a no op or
like a warning message you'll actually
get an error if you try to use illegal
access permits but i don't know the
timeline on when that's going to happen
uh one last thing is
also added in java 17 something that was
uh i think
not talked about enough is within the
javadoc they added the
um both the difficile javadoc they added
a thing where it sells like new apis and
new
modules packages classes interface and
everything that has been added
for every version of java since java 17
or java 11
which can be a really great way to track
all like the new methods or classes that
have been added
like a really good example is string
a lot of new helper methods have been
added to string over uh the recent
releases of java that can make it things
working with string a lot easier
um but this is definitely worth checking
out because a lot of that a lot of these
changes they fall below the level of a
jep so it can be kind of hard to know
what has actually been changed or added
so definitely check this out and this
change for javadoc the how they did this
is actually a change made to the javadoc
tool itself so if you're
a library developer for either a public
library or open source library that's
being used by the full java community
this could be a really great way of
sharing information of like what new
changes have been added or if you're
just working on a library internally
that maybe be is used by across a lot of
teams organization um this new javadoc
uh
sense api can be a great way of sewing
like hey these are the new changes that
have been recently added to this library
with this release
so let's just take a quick look into the
future of
java i'm going to get kind of wrapped
here pretty quickly um but
as i talked about earlier uh pattern
matching is going to become increasingly
a bigger part
of the um future of java
and one of the next new changes for
pattern matching that's going to be
added is pattern matching for switch and
so what it's going to allow you to do is
allow you to do like null um cases uh it
will also allow to do things like
uh guarded patterns so here you can
instead of having to put like um this
check on an area to see if it's like a
large triangle versus like a normal
small triangle size like you normally
would have to do like case and then like
an if you know within the case statement
now you can actually put that as a part
of the case statement itself of course
um there's kind of like you would with
like uh
an exception like you can't have like a
earlier case dominate uh a following
case so if we put this triangle t in
front of this one um then obviously that
would always cover all the cases for
this one so
you know there's proper ordering within
this as well for the guarded patterns
also records gonna become a lot easier
to work with instead of here like okay i
have my my string array or not records
but in this case arrays
uh
my array that you know whatever size it
needs to be and then like i would have
to like you know do like okay get out of
this string away
item one artist first item item zero
item one and do whatever work i want
with it
now i can just directly reference those
array items here and it's just a little
bit cleaner and easier to work with
also
the deconstruction and patterns for
working with records will also
see some improvements in upcoming
releases of java as well but yeah amber
is delivering a lot of new features um
to actually kind of see a lot of that
road map
uh let's see i think this is 2019 2018
um when brian goetz and gavin biermann
uh they put together a guy like this
pattern mansion for java and really
you can see
how
this was all kind of like proposed back
in 2018 but now we see how a lot of
these features actually have been
delivered in subsequent releases of java
and so also from that you can get a
really good sense
of where java is going in some of the
next upcoming releases that's going to
kind of be being delivered from project
amber
be sure to check out early access build
uh so
jdk 18 we just integrated the
um let's see which one was it uh the
um we implemented the core reflection
from method handles so it would be
definitely really great if if you could
test your applications against java 18
to see if you see any sort of
performance regressions or anything like
that
because we definitely want to know that
because this is a really important
reimplementation that kind of is going
to be simplifying a lot of code for us
but it would be important to know that
this isn't going to cause any sort of
regressions for users so definitely if
you can
test your code against java 18 or any
upcoming early access releases to see
how these
um
so you can find them
let's see
uh where
now blank i thought sometimes it's
supposed to be there solve it 18 early
there we go and i'll post that into the
chat so yeah jdk yeah they are jk jobs
java.net um
18 you know or put whatever release you
want in there to get to the early access
build so eventually before long we'll
start having um early access bills for
java 19 once weekend to ramp down phase
one for jdk 18.
other early x oh yeah actually there i
had the link right there
in my presentation as well
we also have a few other major projects
loom panama and valhalla so loom is
going to be introducing virtual threads
which is going to be a pretty
substantial change to how we allow
parallelization within java so it's
definitely worth checking out if that's
going to be something that's really
important for your organization panama
is going to be re-changing the
native access for the native
java native access interface
um so definitely again if your
organization is doing a lot of native
interfaces access work uh panama is
something important to check out and
finally valhalla is going to be
reworking a lot of the value types
within java so like um integer
long boolean and so on it's going to be
kind of a fundamental rework to those
concepts within java as well as a few
other related ones so again
if some of these things are important to
your organization it can definitely be
worth checking these out to provide
feedback
or just get an idea of where we're going
to go with implementing some of these
concepts in the
a little bit farther out future for java
but hopefully some of these things will
start to i mean they're all kind of you
know seeing certain things being
um implemented for example uh i think
with java 18 or
some sort of releasing release where
all the constructors for value types
like integers long and so on have
actually been um
deprecated and that was part of project
valhalla it's kind of sitting paved its
way for it so
uh but hopefully these will all start to
see real
um
concepts being implemented into the
core open jdk or trunk of open jdk here
and the next year or two
uh so plenty examples uh code examples
as well you can check them all out here
um so check that out also i know many
java developers were on
are still on java eight and this is a
really great blog article from uh
a developer at netflix
um that kind of dealt with like that
move from java 8 in this case to java 11
and primarily it kind of came down to
just
upgrading your uh
dependencies for the applications you're
working on there's a few actual code
changes he would occasionally had needed
to do but like ninety percent of the
work was just upgrading the dependencies
really was just something we should be
doing anyways completely independent
of you know which version of java we're
on just to make sure we're kind of
keeping our application secure
from outside threats and as well as
being able to take advantage of the
latest news cools features within
whatever dependencies you're using
uh with that said
thank you and if you have any questions
feel free to unmute yourself and uh and
ask away